[Música]
saludé directo américa de france 24 ya
está con nosotros en el estudio más
romeros a la mar vamos a hablar de las
herramientas para entender estudios
científicos y saber si realmente son
fiables o no pero yo creo que nos hagas
una confesión a mí a la audiencia
cuéntame alguna vez has leído alguno de
los artículos que hemos hablado aquí en
salud
porque hoy en fort es crisis no lo que
usted le explica también yo simplemente
espero que usted no lo explica todos
nosotros claro bueno muy bien salvado
pero la verdad es que entiendo que eso
suceda porque es que a veces puede ser
un verdadero galimatías también llegar a
entender un estudio científico por eso
aquí vamos a recoger unas herramientas
que nos sirvan para poder ser un poco
críticos también no creer todo lo que a
veces se replica en los medios de
comunicación que no sean francos en
teatro o por what's up por ejemplo no
hay muchas veces que ponen según un
estudio esa es la justificación a todo
lo que explican después primero pues
desconfiar siempre de estos titulares y
segundo les invito a hacer clic en estos
estudios en estos enlaces para
enfrentarnos a toda esta literatura
científica que a veces puede ser tan
compleja de entender vamos a poner un
ejemplo como están divididos como están
estructurados estos estudios un estudio
que hablamos hace poco sobre el origen
del cob y 19 vemos que siempre tienen
unos títulos enredados no luego viene 1
párrafo que se llama el abstract este es
importante porque explica las preguntas
que se hacen como los dan respuesta a
una especie de resumen o los principales
hallazgos luego que tenemos los
resultados perdón los autores del
estudio noah y podemos ver por ejemplo
en donde trabajan cuál es su campo de
experticia y también la financiación
autores en afiliase jones todos los
estudios lo tienen y por qué es
importante por ejemplo esto de la
financiación pues porque por ejemplo en
estudios particularmente como en el
campo de la nutrición a veces o en las
farmacéuticas pueden haber intereses
sobre las personas que financian este
estudio y puede haber un ciego un sesgo
no sobre qué resultados se publican y
qué resultados no importante cuál decir
que quien financia el estudio que algo
sea privado no siempre es malo porque
hacer un estudio es muy caro requiere
mucho tiempo muchos recursos y a veces
pues no siempre las instituciones
públicas pueden permitírselo luego
también un párrafo que habíamos visto
que aparecía aquí que se llama el límite
jce jones si no hay párrafo controles de
buscar limitations explica muy bien
normalmente cuáles son pues dónde se
queda corto el audio y cuáles son las
limitaciones otra información valiosa si
ese estudio sprint es decir es una
versión pre impresa todavía no ha estado
revisada por pares este sistema como
funciona pues una revista cuando reciba
un artículo lo que hace es mandárselo a
expertos del mismo campo científico para
que revisen los datos las conclusiones
la metodología y si tienen la luz verde
pues entonces se publica eso da algo más
de fiabilidad aquí vemos un artículo por
ejemplo que es una versión pri print pre
impresa no han sido revisada esto
significa que no tengan información
valiosa no significa que los que en
cambio si han sido revisados por pares
sean la verdad absoluta pues tampoco
todas las revistas pueden llegar a
publicar morralla incluso las más
prestigiosas pero nos ofrece algo de
orientación para saber qué tan fiables
son más minuciosos digamos mari le
pregunté que es el más importante
entender entonces estos estudios
científicos sí pues mira nosotros lo
preguntamos a sergio ferrer que es un
periodista científico y es colaborador
de science media center de españa y lo
explica la verdad mucho mejor que
nosotros
todo estudio intenta responder una
pregunta y no otra vale
entonces lo primero que intento ver es
que pregunta está intentando responder
este estudio después de eso
creo que una tercera parte importante es
ver las limitaciones vale todo esto iba
a tener limitaciones no sé 4 un estudio
perfecto entonces es entender las aves
que son muy obvias a veces simplemente
que es un fármaco muy prometedor pero
que es aprobado con ratones marc cómo
entender entonces estas limitaciones
también de las que habla bastante
york-mets bueno pues estas limitaciones
muchas veces forman parte por ejemplo de
cómo se intenta responder esta pregunta
que tiene el estudio científico esa
hipótesis que se están planteando no hay
muchas veces en ciencias de la salud lo
que es más importante también es la
muestra sobre quién se realiza este
estudio vamos a poner también dos
ejemplos de este es el estudio sobre la
hepatitis infantil desconocida que
también habíamos hablado en programas
anteriores vemos que el estudio sólo se
basa en nueve casos de niños que se
habían enfermado y 58 sujetos de control
es decir niños que no tenían este tipo
de enfermedad es una muestra real
pequeña definitivamente una de sus
limitaciones que solo se basa en estas
pocas decenas de casos y nueve niños
enfermos sin embargo sigue siendo
valiosa la información a pesar de que
tenga estas limitaciones porque tenemos
la información valiosa que sin embargo
luego se tiene que seguir investigando
luego otro ejemplo cuando la muestra es
con animales vamos a poner otro ejemplo
de un estudio en el que se pudo hacer
caminar a unos monos que tenían unas
lesiones medulares no en la médula
espinal vemos que de 9 - que se usaron
sólo dos estaban lesionados la muestra
es muy pequeña no entonces sin embargo
eso significa que sea malo no este mismo
estudio luego también fue el que
permitió que se replicará en algunos
pocos pacientes humanos sin embargo pues
siempre tener en cuenta que cuanto más
grande la muestra suele ser más adecuado
también suele proporcionar información
más valiosa y de nuevo no es lo mismo
los animales nunca que en los humanos
así es marie le pregunto errores más
comunes que cometemos cuando se publican
estos estudios pues yo creo que la
verdad regula el primer error es
intentar encontrar siempre la verdad
absoluta en la ciencia son nunca sucede
y así nos lo explicaba también a sergio
ferrer
al final un paper un estudio nunca jamás
va a ser muy rara vez va a ser pues el
punto y final de un asunto y va a cerrar
un tema y va a zanjar una controversia
ni nada por el estilo
un estudio simplemente una piedrecita
más en un largo camino no de evidencias
que al final les llegan hasta con seis
pero bueno yendo un poco lo concreto
vamos a poner tres ejemplos de errores
comunes que se suelen cometer el primero
es extrapolar una conclusión
pequeña y pasarlo a lo absoluto por
ejemplo un estudio que se preguntan si
unos niños con mascarillas o no se
contagiaron de kobe pongamos que 500
niños en una escuela pues no hubo un
repunte de casos una vez se quitaron las
mascarillas eso es lo que encuentra el
estudios es la pregunta y esa su
respuesta sin embargo que no podemos
hacer nosotros asumir a partir de eso
que las mascarillas no sirven de nada
que no sirven para prevenir los
contagios por ejemplo de kobe de cine
que no podemos hacer tampoco confundir
la correlación con causalidad es por
ejemplo vamos a ver un ejemplo muy
exagerado que de hecho nos explicaba a
sergio también en la entrevista que le
hicimos por ejemplo el país donde más
con chocolate es suiza el país que más
premios nobel tiene por cabeza por
cápita es suiza por lo tanto concluimos
y nos quedamos tan anchos que comer
chocolate nos hace más inteligentes y
nos va a hacer ganar premios nobel eso
que parece muy exagerado y me lo dio
obvio que no es así también pasa en los
estudios por ejemplo el de las vacunas
de ccoo y 19 los cambios en la
menstruación cogemos una variable que es
pues que estas personas se han vacunado
y otra que es que han tenido cambios en
la menstruación esto explica que se
correlacionen no podemos estar seguros y
para terminar nunca podemos sacar de
contexto así haya un pequeño estudio o
un estudio que muestre que por ejemplo
el alcohol es beneficioso siempre
tenemos que tener en cuenta que esto se
enmarca en un contexto donde el consenso
científico es que el alcohol es malo
para la salud entonces recordar que la
ciencia se construye poco a poco estudio
a estudio y nunca darlos como si fueran
la verdad absoluta